بالفعل ما ان بدا هذا المؤتمر حتى بدات
التصاريح تتوالى والاعلانات تتوالى
الانسانيه تحديدا السعوديه اعلنت عن هذه
حزمه المشاريع التي
خصصتها للمشاريع الانسانيه
وقالت بانها هي متنوعه لكافه متضرريه زجاج
سواء في سوريا او تركيا على حد سواء سواء
من عمليه توفير المسكن
المؤقت للمتضررين في تركيا وسوريا
بالاضافه الى توفير عمليات اللغات
المستمره
والقيام بعمليات
التوفير المساكن بشكل عام للمتضررين الذين
سيبكثون طوال الاشهر القادمه في اماكن
مفتوحه وخارج منازلهم بالاضافه الى ذلك
بدات جلسات المؤتمر او المنتدى
لمشاركه واسعه من عدد من المنظمات الدوليه
التابعه للامم المتحده والمنظمات الاخرى
العامله سواء كان الصليب الاحمر او من
الهجره او المنظمات الاخرى التي حضرت
بمستوى رفيع اتحدث عن مستوى رؤساء
ومفوضين سامين وتحدثوا خلال الجلسات
الاولى عن ابرز التحديات التي تواجه العمل
الانساني بالاضافه الى التحدي الكبير الذي
يواجه هذه العمليه وهو تحدي التمويل
وذكروا بان الذكرة مارتن المساعد الامير
العام لمنظمه المتحده لشؤون الانسانيه بان
330 مليون شخص يحتاج لعمليات اغاثه عاجله
بالتالي هنالك
مشاورات او محاورات وايضا طرح مواضيع
حياله التمويل خصوصا بان المعلومات
الوارده من هذا المؤتمر بان
المنتدى بان اكبر عشره ممولين في العالم
او العمليات التموينيه في العام في العالم
هي لعشره الدول منها السعوديه هي الاكبر
في التالي هي ذكر
المنظمات العامله هنا في المشاركه
بان هذه العمليه غير مستدامه وهم يرغبون
بالحصول على تمويل اضافي من بشكل مستدام
من مختلف الجهات التمويليه او حتى بعمليه
مستدامه اخرى بالاضافه الى ذلك نايف تحدثت
قبل قليل مع السيد روبرت مارديني مدير عام
اللجنه الدوليه لصليب الاحمر الذي اجرينا
مع مقابله وقال بان عمليه مفاوضات تجري
بين الصليب الاحمر وبين الجهات المسيطره
على ادلب كذلك بالاضافه الى النظام السوري
لادخال عمليات المساعدات الطبيه الى ادلب